As an alternative to flu shots the flu patch
concept is equipped with 50 microneedles around
the size of a hair follicle that penetrate
the skin to deliver the vaccine.
And Researchers at Plymouth University found
that people trying to quit eating certain
foods or smoking cigarettes can help stave
off cravings by simply playing three minutes
of Tetris.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
Scientists have studied the direct link between
our brain and the motion-sensing cells in
our eyes.
Although we've known for a half century of
these cells that help us know when something
is moving - they've now studied the direction-sensing
cells link to the cortex which could help
us understand things like dyslexia.
A new app is designed to predict your future.
Predictables is a contemporary fortune teller
that uses an algorithm to search for patterns
in your life to help predict what you should
do next.
By searching your calendar, Facebook friends,
and your interaction with the digital world
it could for instance, alert you if your significant
other is having a bad day and suggest that
you get them flowers.
The PrioVR is a wireless virtual reality gaming
suit.
It's made up of body sensors to give you the
ultimate 360 degree, low latency, real-time
motion-tracking experience.
There are three versions - an 8 sensor upper
body unit for sitting on the couch - a 12
sensor unit for full body tracking, and a
17 sensor unit that adds extra control to
the shoulders, feet, and hips.
Researchers at UC Berkeley are working on
a renewable energy source that harnesses the
power of waves.
The sea floor carpet consists of a thin sheet
of rubber sitting atop hydraulic cylinders
that pump as it moves up and down with the
motion of the waves, the hydraulic pressure
is then pumped to the shore and converted
into power.
GE is on the cusp of a refrigerator revolution
by using magnets.
The process of using magnetic material is
projected to be 20 percent more efficient
than traditional methods and it uses a water
based fluid flowing through a series of magnets
to create heat rather than a chemical refrigerant
and compressor.
Recycling these fridges would be much easier
on the environment and they hope to have it
available within the next decade.
This drone is able to fly for five years without
refueling because it runs on power of the
sun!
The MarkOne is a 3D printer that is able to
print the lightest strongest material in the
world.
It's able to print continuous carbon fiber
which is stronger than metal.
This breakthrough has applications ranging
from prosthetics and robotics to making motorcycle
parts.
And it ships in the second half of 2014.
Emospark claims to be the first artificially
intelligent emotion device.
It's an android-powered wifi cube that lets
users interact through conversation, music,
and visual media.
Over time the cube creates an emotional profile
graph, essentially allowing it to feel and
express those emotions according to the user.
And seek joy and satisfaction from its owner.
Computer simulations have shown that using
offshore wind turbines can drastically reduce
the power of hurricanes.
By encountering an enormous wind farm stretching
many miles offshore and along the coast Professor
Mark Z Jacobson found that hurricane wind
speeds could be reduced by up to 92 miles
per hour and the storm surge decreased by
up to 79 percent and he says that 78,000 wind
turbines off the coast of New Orleans would
have drastically changed the outcome of Hurricane
Katrina.
The world's oldest cheese dates back to 1615
BC and was recently discovered as clumps on
the neck and chests of Chinese mummies.
So yeah.
The Florida International University Discovery
Lab is developing a real Robocop!
Sort of.
The Telebot prototype is designed to help
disabled police officers.
The 6 foot tall, 75 lb robot can be controlled
remotely by officers and the head has live
video streaming in order to share visual information.
The next step is developing the outer shell
and doing field testing.
Finally, here's a responsive hexi wall made
up of 60 moving modules created by Thibaut.
I'm going to leave you with Bimanual Manipulation
for Autonomous Service Robots and as always
- thanks for watching.